hi everyone is Kenneth from vias code
today I'm here to talk about the new kid
huh Bullock wrist extension that we are
made in collaboration with the github
team over the past many months we have
been busy collaborating with github and
enabling a rich puller cress experience
inside vias code
today we announcing the public preview
of github Pollock rests which is a new
optional experience that you can install
as an extension for vias code the
extension allows you to authenticate and
connect vs code to github it allows you
to list and browse pull requests from
within vias code you can review pull the
crest within it it's accommodating and
where we also added markdown support we
are also enabling a more natural PR
workflow within editor check out that
enables you to use rich language
features such as go to definition and
intelligence and lastly we enabling a
smooth terminal integration and that
enables the UI in vias code to coexist
with the get CLI github pull requests is
a new type of vias code extension it's
powered by a new set of api's we have
baked into the core Avia's code in order
to enable code reviews and comedy
but enough talk let me show you how it
works
so what I have here is the insiders
edition of vias code I have a folder
open called pool crest demo which is a
node application we have put together to
actually demonstrate this new pool of
crest experience the new thing you have
here is that if you go to the source
control section in vias code you'll
notice that that we now have this new
viewlet here called github pull requests
what you can see in this view lid is
that you can see some categories of pull
requests that are available for me to
browse and that's one category here
called waiting for me waiting for my
review so I can expand this category and
what you'll see here is that that's
actually a pull request and this
particular project that's waiting for my
review so I can go expand it and what
you see is that I can I can kind of get
a description of what this pull request
is all about but can also see that the
fab I can in this P is deleted and I can
kind of see that there's some index of
Jas has been modified but but what I do
here is that I just click on this script
description so I have what I'm presented
with here is an overview of this
particular pull request I can kind of
see that its name like update route
titles it's something about like the
route rods are being simplified and I
can see you Rachel he and my team has
been adding some feedback or adding a
comment after some of the changes you
made and so like I'm a bit curious to
know more about the changes you made so
I can just go out here and I can open up
routes the route index.js file what I'm
presented here with is a diff editor
that is just giving me a nice overview
of the changes in this particular pull
request and I can see like she's been
kind of adding a comment to this is this
too generic
and you know what like this is kind of
the same experience that I haven't
github and I think this is cool but but
we can also do do better so if I go back
to to the github or overview page what
you'll see that we have in the top is
that we have this new button called
check out this the this workflow enables
me to check out the work the probe
request by checking out locally on my
computer and then enables me to do it
like an in-depth review of the code
if I click it what you'll now see is
that it's now checked out this
particular pull request I am now in a
review mode and if you go down here to
the bottom you can kind of see my branch
selector has chain
it's now checked out that particular
branch for the public rest and what's
cool is that we do now also see a new
view lat here envious cold called
changes in public rest here kind of had
the same description page that I had
before I can kind of see the changes but
kinda I can also see the commits that
were that's inside this particular PR
and down here at the bottom I kind of
have a new panel that we call the
Commons panel this is panelist gives me
an overview of all the Commons that has
been added in the this particular PR and
I I'm a bit curious to see more about
Rachel's comment so I can just click
here at the bottom and what you see here
that I'm taking straight to the Indus
index.js file with Rachel's Commons
shown in line inside my editor so you
know what like she's asking is like this
is this is too generic you know what I
actually think this looks pretty good to
me so what I can do is I can just add
the comment and bam I just added the
comments straight from my editor but the
the key thing here is that because the
source code for this particular poll
Chris is checked out locally on my
computer is that I can also start taking
advantage of someone like the code
intelligence so if I scroll up here in
my code I can kind of see that some of
my my variables here are kind of grayed
out so you can kind of see that request
is declared but this is actually never
used I can see here that there's a
variable here called product ID that is
never used so what I can do here is that
it says is this strictly related to to
Rachel's changes but I can add a comment
and saying here looks like product ID
isn't used maybe remove and if I can fix
my type it was here then you can see
here that I've just took advantage of
like rich language features inside my
editor and I can I now apply that
knowledge straight on my PR but yes but
overall I kind of think that you know
Rachel's changes looks looks pretty good
and but this deleted fav I can out here
makes me a bit worried like I don't know
if this is like kind of having some
impact on the code so what I can do here
is that I can go to the integrated
terminal inside VIU's code and I can
actually run my application I can
validate the things are working so it's
a node app so I can just do a NPM stop
and what we are actually seeing here is
at my node app when I run in p.m. star
is crashing it's not working and if I
look at the error here this error is
actually related to the to the missing
fab I can so this is some somehow
required for the app to boot and this is
interesting because if I just reviewed
this outside of my my editor I would not
have been able to catch an error like
this
so Rachel poppy just like she deleted
this by mistake or something but I
should let her know so what I can do is
that I can go back to the description
page I can add a holistic comment and
this this pull the question saying looks
like the build is broken
deleted fab I can by a mistake and
you're not I can just say like I will
request some changes because this
doesn't work and bam I just requested
some changes there's now being b-being
says this and to github so now I'm kind
of finished with my my pull requests
here and so the way I can exit my my my
review is that I can either go up here
and click the the exit review mode
button and but because I'm kind of a
terminal kind of guy what I can do is
that I can just go straight down here to
the integrator terminal and I can just
say git checkout master because I don't
just want to go back to the master
branch and what you see here is that I
just checked out my master branch but
vias code was kind of picking that
change up from the CLI that yourself you
now see that the comments panel down
here is is gone the changes in this
particular PR viewlet is gone and I'm
just back to my regular master branch
and I can continue my work and this kind
of a nice way for me to finish my my
code with you and I don't I don't need
to leave my editor I can just use the
tools that are always used that was the
demo today we announcing the public
preview of github pull requests it's a
preview so we need your feedback to make
it better you can find in our
marketplace so please try it out and let
us know what you think and github and
twitter we're really excited I'm
bringing code reviews inside the editor
and on behalf of github and the villa's
code team happy coding
you